Maybe a small startup running a private program will have like a small cheese,
so a small set of holes. But giant companies has like a way bigger market share, so the cheese is
big. And so there is more holes. And that's how I approach my targets right now. The metaphor works
and I will fight anyone that say otherwise.
All righty, Richard, what's on the docket for today? An ASMR ad? Say less. I got you. I got you.
All right, guys. So today we're going to attack surface management roles, not AS. Okay, I got you.
Well, if we're talking about attack surface management, then of course, we're talking about
the Asinode team, right? The OGs in the ASM space. And this time around, they've released a new
community project, their attack surface management job board, a place where you can see all of the
companies that are hiring for attack surface management jobs. So if you're interested in
that sort of thing, if you're a recon heavy hacker, or if you just want to get your hands on the Asinode
product to play around with it, definitely check out that job board. That's going to be at
acidnote.io slash...
acidnote.io slash ASMR. I'm going to make them change it to ASMR. So if you want to support the pod,
or if you want to check out that job board, head over to acidnote.io slash ASMR. All right, back to the
show. Let's go. Alrighty, man. Here we are. Hey, it's, it's been a fun week. We are sitting down
right now in Grenoble at Ronnie's studio here. And I came into town for Grrach and Ronnie...
Grrach.
Grrach. I can't get the R correct. But Ronnie showed me an excellent time. And,
you know, I had a plan for this pod, Ronnie, but then you had a plan as well for this pod.
I'm so sorry.
No, no, I'm open to it. I'm open to it, man. We're just chilling. So, what were you thinking?
Yeah, I was thinking that, like, recently I've been helping a friend of mine into getting into
bug bounty hunting. And the interesting thing is that from someone that is completely beginner,
just a little bit passionate about computers, I noticed how hard it is to get all the concepts
that we know today, right? And you did, like, a great thread at the time on Twitter that I actually
sent it to him. And I'm noticing how he's trying to learn from your thread. And I think that
beginners tutorials need to be a bit more hardcore.
I see. I see. Okay. Okay.
And so the goal is, like, um, face it in your thread, the first thing that comes to mind is,
like, the web fundamentals, right? And, like, how do you really start into web? What do you learn
exactly? And there's so many, you know, resources, but I guess, like, the best ones are the most
technical ones. And if you start with the hardest one, like the RFC, the MDN documentation, stuff
like that, you are going to get to the roots and the fundamentals of what is really web. And that
will help you for your bug bounty journey. I'm going to go ahead and pull up the tweet right
here. We'll show it on the screen. But essentially, it's just a description of what I would do over the
course of a year if I was to try to go from zero to 100k in bug bounty. And yeah, web fundamentals,
I think that's one of the areas where I've gotten the most questions.
Yes.
You know, is like, what, what does a web fundamental, you know, education include?
Um, so yeah, we can talk a little bit about that. And I think also, you know, this may be one of the
episodes, the one of the rare episodes of critical thinking that might be a little bit more beginner
oriented, but I think as more advanced hackers as well, it can be helpful to reflect on these things,
not only for the purposes of being able to teach them to the next generation of hackers, but also as
a sort of a reflection ourselves on the basics and what it looks like to develop those basics.
Yeah. Yeah. Especially since we were talking about like availability that you saw an article about
on GitHub, where it's used like the head verb, HTTP verb as a way to exploit it. And like, it just shows
that sometimes you need to go back to the roots and the basics and go way deeper into the, you know,
the fundamentals of what is the technology that the technologies that you are trying to hack and how,
like as an expert in the field and how, as a beginner, you can go straight to the, you know,
yeah, the root of that kind of technology in order to restart your exploitation journey.
Yeah. And I think that's one of the things that's really pivotal too, about learning,
um, hacking, because we were talking in that same conversation as we were hiking up the mountain,
exactly. Uh, you know, that when you, hacking is sort of a unique thing because it's not like
once you learn it, you're good. You know, like every single time we hack something, we are relearning,
you know, we, we have to take that product, that, that application or whatever, and we have to break it
down just like we did in the beginning when we were learning the skills for hacking
and, uh, and find the problems with it. Um, and so we can't really teach hacking without teaching
the ability to learn, uh, the ability to learn an application and, and, and that, that whole,
that whole flow. Um, and, and, and I think we can apply that as well. You know, we do it every time
we hack an application, we, we do what we needed to do, um, you know, back in the day when we were just
starting, uh, except, you know, at that point we're, we're doing it against a whole industry,
a whole, a whole set of, um, technologies, HTTP, you know, web browsers, that sort of thing.
Um, so it's, it's a lot wider scale, right? You know, you might, you might say it's the biggest,
uh, set of applications there might be out there. Um, but it, essentially it's, it's the same principles
just applied at a larger scale. And then at a smaller scale, once you sort of have the basic
understanding of what vulnerabilities exist on these sort of attack surfaces.
Yeah. And, and there, there is something that, uh, you are grasping right now that I think,
uh, a lot of beginners, but I know also a lot of real expert people in the field that are trying
to get into bug bounty. So they're bug bounty beginners, but already experienced cybersecurity is
that the ability to find the good resources in order to help you exploit some, some vulnerabilities.
Like the, the question that we get the most in our DMS is like, okay, where do I learn stuff?
Like how I find the information? And I think this is a huge problem for us to answer this one, because
the goal is not to give the knowledge to someone is like to get the ability for them to find their,
their own knowledge. Because when you are going to, to get like this really weird, uh, technology that
exists just on two web servers in the world, you are not going to get a Google search or anyone on
earth that is going to know it, right? You need to go down into the documentation, the technical
spec and really understand it yourself. And that's how you really find the, the information just trying
to get to face, uh, the, the, the most technical and route thing. And why we, we, we, we, we take your
direct, your tread, the web fundamentals where, when I'm trying to teach someone and just give like them
the MDN documentation, which is. I would say the beginner friendly version of some RFC. Uh, and then I, I
tell them like to try to, to find the same information in the RFC, uh, that is more complete, right? So when you're
learning HTTP, uh, it's great to actually learn what is HTTP, what it's built on top of. So TCP, uh, TCP IP,
uh, how do you reach, uh, a domain? What is a host? What is an IP and everything? And like go to the
root fundamentals because sometimes in those routes, there is like some big vulnerabilities.
Yeah. I mean, that's, that's the kind of stuff you see with James Kettle all the time is he, he's, you know,
sort of peeling back those layers and addressing, uh, the vulnerabilities at a lower level. Um,
yeah, I think that's definitely important. I, I think it's difficult to give also resources like
MDN or the RFC or whatever, and say like, Hey, these are the, the, you know, source of truth for
these things, because at the end of the day, like you said, you have to, you have to go and find them,
you know, and, uh, and, and so, yeah, absolutely reading the RFC and an MDN is a really great
resource and, and something that, that we should do. Um, but there's also going to be, you know,
those random little, little forums out there, you know, with some do some old Linux geezer,
you know, that knows that was there when this, you know, obscure period of protocol was created
and you got to read that too. And so it's a lot of, it's a lot of digging and a lot of, like you said,
you know, not necessarily being intimidated by these, uh, these highly technical documents,
because at the end of the day, this is what I always tell myself, you know, when I'm shaking
in my boots in front of like this, you know, very scary target is like at the end of the day, somebody
not that much smarter than me, probably, you know, wrote this whole thing, right? Right. And, you know,
sure there, there are some like, you know, mega genius people out there that are just, you know,
leagues above us all, but I feel like given enough time, I can, I can, uh, you know, compensate for
the difference, you know? So, um, you know, remember, remembering that these people aren't
gods, you know, that this is not something beyond my, my, you know, ability to grasp,
we just have to put in the time to get there. Um, so yeah, I think, and then also, you know,
on the web fundamentals, just going back to the nuts and bolts of the web fundamentals,
I think, um, it's hard to know where to draw the line on those sorts of things, right? Like,
do I need to know what every single header does? You know, do I need to know what every single
object on window, you know, in the JS engine of Google, you know, Chrome, Chromium or whatever,
do I need to know what all those means? And the answer is no, but it wouldn't hurt, you know,
you know, like, you know, you can always spend more time going down that path. And that's one of the
reasons why in this article, I, I outline or in the tweet thread, um, I outline this ratio of
hacking to learning where in the beginning, you're going to be spending, you know, 80% of your time
or more on learning. And, and, and, but it's very important to get that, you know, 20%, 10% of the
time actually hacking. So, you know, where, where things are making a difference.
Yeah. And yeah, that's actually an interesting thing, like on like trying to learn everything,
like, where do you stop? Like, do you need every header? And I think like, you need to learn enough
to be able to manipulate yourself the data and to be able to find back where you can, uh, learn, uh,
the, for instance, like a specific header, uh, you need to know where in the documentation,
you can, you can find it back. That's a good point. Yeah. It's not about learning,
like having like the, the strong knowledge of, of, uh, the RFC. It's about trying to understand how
you can read the RFC in order to find back the knowledge. Right. Um, I, I think there, there is
an Einstein quote, or at least many people attribute that to Einstein saying like, why, why would you
search, uh, something like, what would you know something that, that you can search for? Right. And I
think it's true to some degree, like you need to understand the overall concept, like the abstract
of it, but what the day you are going to need to, to get, you know, your hands dirty, you need to find
back where you, you, you, you learn this from and in order to go even deeper in this specific technology.
Um, yeah, that's one of the things I've struggled with as well as like, uh, as far as needing a good
notes system for that sort of thing. Right. Like I'll often think, I know I read an article,
where there was like some similar technology to this and I, I just need to find that now,
you know, and I, and I can't find it no matter, you know, how well I Google dork.
Um, and, and for a little while I was using like this clipper, um, like the Evernote, uh,
web clipper or something like that. Um, but I, I, I've since stopped using that and I feel like I need
to find a good solution for that again, you know, to be able to reach back and grab that. But,
um, yeah, I guess what other stuff do we need to cover in the web fundamentals area? I mean,
I guess one of the things I always talk over with the beginners is like, what is actually happening
when you are interacting with a web server via your web browser? Right. Yeah.
What do you, I feel like even before like how it is interacting, I feel that you need to learn how
you, you need to interact yourself with, uh, the, the backend system that you are trying to reach. But
again, I guess it's, it's better like curl. Yeah. You think like curl or maybe even the netcat or something.
Oh, like netcat and like printf. Yeah. Like, like just for one single reason, how many times you sent a
get request on burp, kaito, or any proxy that you are using and you forgot the two, uh, trailing lines.
Oh, the, the new lines at the end. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. 100%. And when you have like a system
like curl or netcat where it's really low level and you control every part of it and you can actually
understand like what specific header or what the path is doing or what the host is doing and just
trying, I don't know, try to reach Google with a netcat and, and trying to do a redirect or something like
that is actually something good to learn because you are controlling every part of, uh, of, of your
requests. And I know like some really good hackers, uh, that actually for request smuggling do not use
any proxy. Yeah. That actually goes on netcat. Yeah. And I think having that lower level ability to play
around with the individual bytes is pretty useful for sure. I I've done it. I've done it only a couple
times myself, but I think it gives you confidence as well that the system is actually as simple as
you think it is, you know, like, like, I think there's always this, um, like, uh, for me, this
sort of like fog of, yeah, maybe like, I think I understand that, but I haven't actually like played
around with it and we got my hands on it yet. So I think there, you know, there could be something that
I don't understand there. And when you actually like just netcat and print F, you know, then it
absolutely like, you know, you know, for sure, oh, I need to put this new line and you know,
I need to do that. And, and you see how granular the control is that you have over all that.
And that's also like this low level, like learning at the beginning, those low level stuff really
going to help you in the future to trust a tool or not. Like that's, that's a great point.
Your, your reliance on the tool, um, like, like this is someone else that coded it for you. Right.
And so you rely on their knowledge and their coding skill. And I mean, of course there are some
amazing, amazing tools, but sometimes you need something like really specific and you don't know
if the tool is going to do it or not. Like, um, uh, myself at the real beginning when Jamskettle, uh,
released the Burp extension for Rika smuggling, you know, I just tried to run it everywhere and I was
like, Hey, it doesn't do anything. It doesn't find any vulnerability. But then I got back with the netcat
request and I was like, Oh wait, why the response is like that? And, and that's, I feel like as a
beginner, I learned something good about that. I learned like what the, the request was and what
data was needed to, to be manipulated inside the request in order to reproduce a vulnerability. Right.
And, uh, yes, it's harder. Uh, it's not for everyone, but I think it's a good advice, even for beginners
or experts to just try to go deeper in your stack and understand like, okay, what am I doing right
now? Like what is really happening behind? Yeah. You said you're not even letting this poor kid use a
web browser at this point, right? Like Ronnie is teaching this kid. And as we were walking up this mountain,
Ronnie's like, yeah, man, the briefing is accurate. You know, I, I don't even let him use, use the
browser at this point. He's just using curl. I'm like the browser is going to do so much things for you.
And, uh, I want, want him to actually learn like the structure of the request. And like, for instance,
if I don't put the right verb, what, what the backend is supposed to answer to me. And then I want him to go
on another system and see if he got the same response because like something as easy as a 302 is like, okay,
what's a 302? Let's go on the MDN. Okay. Look at the MDN, read it and tell me what's the 302 doing. Oh, it's a
redirect. What's a redirect? Uh, I don't know. Okay. Learn what's a redirect and what's the redirect. Okay.
Apparently it's giving me a path to go to. Can you find the path to go to in the response? It's like, there's nothing in the
body. I mean, Hey, there you go. That's a good, that's a good discovery. And that's, and that's
why I told him use that cat, see the full request or curl with the dash I and they're like, oh my God,
there is a location header and like, okay, you see. And that's where I, I understood something really,
really important is that the tool I, uh, you know, of first skin of, of the skating a lot of what it is
doing. And if you really want to learn web fundamentals, it's going to help you to go to the
documentation and just trying to, you know, to actually generate yourself those low level, uh, requests.
And adding that VVV, you know, getting the actual raw, you know, HTTP request base. Exactly. It sounds like, you know,
with this guy that you're, that you're working with, you're using a lot of the Socratic method, sort of like asking the question that he needs to go find the answer to.
And, and, and I think that's really helpful. Um, and it also teaches him how to ask the correct
question for himself at some point. Exactly. Um, I'm just such a big fan of that education model.
This, the Socratic method, it can be kind of a pain in the ass. Like, I'm sure this guy's going to punch you
in the next time he sees you in person. Exactly. I, I, I told him like, uh, if I think that the question
is not good enough, I'm just going to let him answer, uh, uh, himself. Right. But if I know that
I struggled myself to find the answer, I'm going to try to help him like find the answer faster. Uh,
I think that's a good way to do because as I told him at the beginning, you need to be able to face
the wall yourself because I'm not going to be there for your bug bounty career and you can't rely
on me and I don't want to, to collaborate with you in the future. Yeah. I don't want to collaborate
with you in the future. Yeah. I like to do my thing on my side. I got this guy, Rhino Raider.
I love to collaborate with him. Yeah. He's a good dude. Yeah. No, that's good. Okay. So we got the
HTTP sort of spec, right? The RFC, the MDN, you've got, um, you know, browser internals. I always,
I always, uh, think it's really important for people to understand how same origin policy works
and like the whole concept of these isolated origins in the browser. Um, and why you can't just
use JavaScript to reach into an iframe and like grab some data out unless it's the same origin iframe
right. And then you can, um, and then understanding what sort of tools you have at your disposal there,
especially if you want to become a good client side hacker, because, um, so much of client side
hacking is just chaining together all these little gadgets that you get into making it into something
that is really impactful. Um, let's see, what else do we have on the, on the web fundamentals, um,
environment there? Yeah. Um, I think like actual structure of the, of the backend could also be
helpful like proxies and, and what frameworks are being used and that sort of thing.
Yeah. I, I, I was going to, to, to mention that one because this is like a huge part of what I'm also
trying to, to teach the, the, this kid right now, uh, is that two different backends, it's, it's, it's
gonna sound obvious, but will not implement the same standard in terms of, uh, of re request response.
Right. Um, I, he sent me a message and like, Hey, I did that option verb on that request and I got a
full three and like, shouldn't be option always, uh, give back all the headers and methods that I,
I can reach. Yeah. Yeah. It's like, Hey, maybe there is something in front, a layer, or maybe they
did something custom. And that's where you, you dig. Like this is like the hacker mindset is like,
what happened and why it is happening and how can I use that on my, uh, in my advantage. Right.
That's a good sign though. I think for him, you know, that he's like, Oh, let me try a different
HTTP verb here. And he's identified an HTTP verb that is actually supposed to like give you data
about a specific endpoint and how it, you know, how it works. Um, yeah, that's, that's a good, that's a
good sign for our boy here, you know, like he's going down the right path.
And, and, and the structure of the backend is like such a good thing. Like I, I'm glad that you put
it on the thread because like just a reverse proxy will not implement the same, for instance, uh, RFC
than, uh, the, the backend. Right. Uh, and just because there is like two types of implementation,
it creates a confusion and you can exploit that, uh, to your advantage. Uh, it, it, it, it, it's like, um,
second order pass traversal, right. It's the, the, the, the same philosophy, the same mindset is that
you have two different layers that are not treating data the same way. And we're not talking like about
the specific vulnerability, specific technology. Like this is an, the abstract thinking of it.
Like you have several layers and you are just trying to jump from one layer to another and trying to see
if they look at the data, uh, differently. Yeah. That's a widely applicable concept is the whole,
the whole, um, disagreement on how data should be processed normally in input from the user.
Yeah. Um, you know, so, so I guess there's like that set of technology, right. Where you need to
understand the, yeah, maybe this was a little bit of an area where that, that tweet was lacking is like,
okay, even though we understand the fundamentals, um, and maybe we understand the individual
vulnerabilities, I think there's some mindset things like you were saying, like, okay, the
overarching principle of mismatch in parsing data or the, the, uh, universal, this is one we talk about
all the time, the universal principle of, uh, context breaks, right. Where we're breaking out and it can
be any context break, right. I, I talk about, you know, maybe the, the most, um, benign version of
this is, is when you have like a cookie and, and you're injecting into the value of the cookie, but
you can also specify the semicolon and inject into the, um, the, the attributes of the cookie, right.
That's a context break. Um, and we also see context breaks in, you know, XSS and all sorts of injection
based stuff. Um, that, that could be, that's something that I haven't seen people really formula
eyes or formalize even in like a blog post of like, what are some of the overarching hacker principles
that you should have in your mind that should start triggering red flags?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. This is, we, we talked about a piece of, I, I, that's a good idea for a piece
of content actually for beginners. I think so. Uh, and, and that's what, you know, uh, earlier today,
Justin was, uh, struggling on the puzzle. Uh, yes, I was, I hate those fricking puzzles, dude.
Yeah. You know, and I think hacking is like much like a puzzle. Like, I totally disagree with that.
I think, I think hacking is like very different than a puzzle. I'm sorry. I hate these puzzles so much
and I feel so comfortable hacking. So when you say that my guttural response is like, hell no.
Yeah. Okay.
But, but, hit me, hit me.
I'm, I'm going to, to, to finish the sentence. It's, it's much like hacking in the, like abstract layer
of thinking, right? You don't, do not need to first check what is happening. Like, uh, uh, that,
that's really hard to formulate, but you don't need to, to just stop at what is in front of you.
You just need to think on the, an abstract layer, like, okay, what is happening? Like, how is my
request reaching the backend? Is there anything in the middle? And like, if there is like a connection,
then there is a rule and this is my rule. This is my world. Okay. And now that I have my rule,
what can I do to break it? And that's, I feel like one of the most low level, um, abstract thinking
that you can do. Like, I admit, at least for me, right? Like you create a rule and you say, okay,
my request is following this rule. Now, or whatever. Yeah. And how I can cheat the game.
And once you have like this abstract thinking, you go down to the technical layers until you write
your requests to hack. Right? Yeah. Yeah. No, that, that does make sense. And that is, I don't know,
man, mapping it onto that stupid freaking little game, you know, is, is where I have the problem with
that. But I think the, the overarching principle does apply. And, uh, it made me think also of a,
another one of the principles is, is this whole concept of time of check to time of use.
Yeah. Right. Like, like, I love that security principle where it's like, okay, you know,
there's some security check that occurs at some point that's trying to prevent you from doing
something. And then after that check, uh, there, that data is, is modified in some way. You know,
the, the classic example for me where I think this really clicked was like back in the day was, um,
an environment in which there was a check being performed for a specific string, you know,
let's say it's script or whatever, trying to prevent cross-site scripting. And then right after that,
there was a replace, uh, you know, call that would, that would, you know, delete something out.
Right. So you could do, you know, uh, you know, open, open bracket, S C R, and then,
you know, whatever it started to start the script tag again. And then it would pull out that middle
piece and it would connect to the two pieces together. Right. And so that, that time of time
of check to time of use, and then there being some sort of modification in between the check and the
use, um, is another one of those overarching principles. So maybe I should have penned that tweet,
I think, and, and add some of these on there as like general principles to be on the lookout for.
Yeah. I think that's a really nice idea. Like trying to, to, to create like category of abstract
thinking, uh, related to, to vulnerabilities, like, like even more abstract than injection.
Right. Like, uh, we, we, we said secondary pass traversal is just because there's two layers that
are not agreeing on what data, uh, how they should pass the data. Right. Uh, all the, the injection
categories, like we are over tracing user input and we can like, this is a brainstorm right now.
Yeah. No, no, no, it's good. It's good. But like, if we try to break down the abstract thinking,
uh, of why we are web hacking that could help, uh, allows people to, to go like on another kind
of methodology, because I, I feel like there is many different methodology. There is one where you just,
um, check box everything, like every kind of vulnerabilities that, that you think, and maybe
it's not efficient, but some people need that. Right. And it's completely like a rational methodology
to use, especially like, if you are like me and you forget what you did earlier.
Yeah. Yeah, for sure.
Uh, but then there is some other people that live in their mind. And so creating like some kind of mind
map of what you think is happening and trying to first check if your mind is correct. Uh, like for
instance, Hey, I think there is like one reverse proxy, a load balancer, and then I can reach the
backend, but the backend is in the cluster. So I have different pods, right? How can I check that? And so
you check that and then, okay, that's my rules. Like I'm evolving in that world. Like this is my mind
map. And, um, and that's helps a lot. Like just being able to confirm that the technology works in
the way that you think it is because you're like, yeah, it's like building these hypotheses and then
validating the assumptions along the way. Yeah. That that's, I think that's a part of the overarching
process. And then we kind of apply these various tenants of, uh, hacker mentality onto that. So like,
another one that I just thought of inspired by Kevin Mizu, uh, you know, from the, the great hacks
presentation, um, is this whole concept of, uh, the mutation XSS that, that he presented, um, is the
whole concept of dealing with user input that is supposed to be spec compliant in some way and is
not spec compliant. So how do we, how do we deal with messy input from the user and get it back to a
place where we, it would like it, it needs to be rendered or it needs to be presented in a way
that's compliant with a specific specification. I think, I think there's vulnerabilities that could,
that, that arise there pretty often. And, and, um, yeah, another one that just, that just comes to
mind as well is I think could be broadly categorized as, um, like lack of depth, uh, of understanding
the technology that you're using, right? The, the, the classic example that comes into mind here is,
um, uh, XXE, right? Where you have this XML language that is just supposed to be for like marking up data
and somehow there's like this weird feature where you can just run arbitrary code, you know, encode
inside of this whole language. And then, you know, you see that as well on top of it with XSLT. And now
it's like, oh, wow, this is a, you know, freaking Turing complete language that that's just built in as a
side component of XML. And it's like, okay, so, you know, there's, there's so many recursive layers of
technical depth, um, to all of these systems that we're using. I mean, you see this with the dependency
confusion stuff too. Yeah. And I, I really like what it was just, you just said as an abstract, abstract
thinking, like, uh, developers misconception of a technology or maybe more like more lack of, uh, root
knowledge. Uh, and you see that with SSRF vulnerabilities, right? So there is an SSRF, uh,
you managed to get your metadata at the end point. There is a fix. What's the fix? Okay. I'm going to
just forbid, uh, the metadata endpoints. Yeah, but there is DNS. Okay. I'm working on another layer.
Okay. I'm just going to forbid any, I do a DNS resolution and forbid anything that resolve to, uh,
to that specific, uh, IP. Yes. But an IP is, uh, just 128 bytes. Yeah. And, but the IFC doesn't say
how you can represent that. There is a convention to represent that with the four dots. Uh, but you
can also represent that in exodecimal and in decimal. Okay. So you just bypassed, uh, the, the check.
Got the DNS rebinding. And then you've got, uh, there's so many technical layers and technical depth
layers. And I think if you specialize in even one of these, um, you know, a high overarching
methodologies, then you can get a lot of vulnerabilities out of it. Right. Like with
these sorts of things, but, uh, being able to apply all of these across a target, I think is what kind
of gives you more of an edge as a, as a hacker, where you feel like, um, you, you get to this point
where you're like, yeah, you know, given enough time, I can probably find a vuln on pretty much
anything, you know? Um, and I think that's what a lot of people are shooting for.
And one question that a lot of beginners also ask a lot in our DMS, I think is okay.
Really great advice. Yeah. I should go look at root things and then apply them to, to my targets. But
what do I aim for? Like what, what's the weird thing that I should aim for? And I guess that the answer
is like, you shouldn't start with research. Uh, you should start with maybe someone else's research.
And that's advice from Jeff Kettle. Like, uh, I think the article is named, uh, Hey, so you want
to be a web security researcher or something like that? I don't remember the exact name, but he says
like hand for forgotten, forgotten knowledge. So basically take the blog posts of someone that you
really understood or really liked the technique and you found it elegant and you, you know, you vibe with
the technique and you're like, okay, I'm going to try to first apply this technique on all the targets
that I know that I like. And I'm like, okay, what works and what doesn't work and why it doesn't work.
And when you apply something at scale, you are going to see all the edge cases. And that's where
your research is starting. That's really good. That's, that's some really good data right there.
Yeah. So, and I, I, I'm saying that because that's how I, I, I started, uh, uh, backbunty.
I was struggling for six months. It's like, I think like, like this was the, everyone's beginner's
story, right? You do not find any vulnerability. You try your checklist, you try everything, but
everyone tried the same thing and you get like a duped open redirect and you are like at this close to,
to just abandon backbunty. And then I was like, okay, let's go to a technology that is widely used,
but maybe people are not looking too into. And I went to WordPress plugins and I was like,
I go to all the targets that are on Hakuon and check which one use WordPress. So you learn a little
bit of recon there, but just enough to have like maybe 1000 websites or maybe even less. Right. And then
you just check any merits, like all the plugins. And I was just aiming at the, the, the smallest
plugins. Right. And I was just checking, Hey, is there an XSS that already exists on the plugin?
And usually like, like checking for CVS against it, or you're saying like actually doing source code
review? Yeah, no, maybe at the beginning, you just check like if there is a CV, if there is a CV,
you have a quick win. And if there was a CV, you check the fix of the CV. And so you start a little
bit of code review and you're like, Hey, I managed to find my XSS. That's another one of the, that's
another one of the overarching principles is the, the fix, right? Like checking, checking the fix at a
granular level, um, and making sure that it's, it's fully technically validated. And I like that.
And, and so for that WordPress research, it wasn't like a huge research, but it was like a little bit
of, of code review and everything. And one day I was doing my excess thingy. I was doing a couple of
hundred bucks, uh, like up to 1000. And I got to a point where, Hey, this XSS is not working on this
specific website. Like it works on my Docker environment of WordPress, but it doesn't work on the website.
And that's where you start learning. Really. It's like, what's the difference?
What is CSP?
Exactly.
That's when you learn what CSP is.
Yeah.
And so you start another deep dive and then that's where the research starts. And
just applying a research at a bit of a larger scale, just trying the same technique,
really niche technique, and then trying to see all the edge cases and from the edge cases,
learn how you create your own research. That's in my opinion, how you can become like a good bug
bounty hunter.
Yeah. That, that at scale piece, I think is really, is really interesting. That, that hasn't been an
approach that I, I think I've implemented a lot, but I, I have seen that the edge case just, uh, you
know, back in the day when I was doing more recon automation, you're absolutely right. Right.
As soon as you try to do something at scale, those edge cases are going to stick out like a sore thumb,
right. Cause they're just going to break your whole system and it's going to be like, ah, why is this
actually not working? Um, so that is a good way to, to find all those little tiny little tweaks off the,
off the edge of what you would normally expect.
And, and that's why sometimes I, I don't rely on tools where I start the research. I prefer to write my
own really buggy tool, like in terms of, of finding stuff really like it, it doesn't,
sorry, it doesn't find like good findings. There is a lot of false positives, but I like to learn
why it is a false positives. Right. And if it's just a blatant false positive, I'm going to fix it.
But then there is like those edge cases, like imagine you are writing an XSS finder tool,
uh, a KIDO plugin or something. And then you just check if there is a reflection, right. And you're like,
Oh, okay. I got my reflection. Then there is XSS, right. And then you understand, Oh, but there
is some tags where like, it doesn't, it doesn't pass as HTML. And so you're like, wait, but can I
actually still get XSS on those tags? And then you go deeper and deeper into the documentation.
You go back to the RFC, you go back to the HTML, MD and documentation, and you are like trying to
understand like this freaking tag, what it is doing because it never used since 2008. Right. It was
just an obscure browser that introduced that. And that, that company.
It sounds like a very specific, uh, problem that you're talking about.
Last eight hours of my time. Yeah, dude.
That was three years ago.
I think that's a really interesting piece though too, because, uh, when I was giving the workshop
at Grehack, um, I kind of said, one of the, I think one of the problems with hackers is that we
often reinvent the wheel time and time again. We make the same tools and why do we rebuild time and time
again, it's because we don't trust the implementation of other hackers because it's opaque in a lot of
scenarios. And I say it's opaque, you know, the source code would still be there, but it's like,
oh, okay, I've got to, you know, sort through all of this source code to make sure that it's properly
implementing, um, you know, my methodology of this is how I would, uh, you know, bypass a 403 or,
you know, look for a fuzz for an XSS in a specific scenario. Right. And so essentially what we
end up doing is then we end up writing the code ourselves so that we know this is, this is how it
should be implemented. Right. Um, because we're, we're essentially taking our own methodology and,
uh, trying to automate it right. And, and build it out. So you can definitely see the various edge
cases pretty well that way. Um, yeah, but, but I think it's not always that, that piece of,
I don't have introspection into the tool. It's also, oh, I want to understand this more thoroughly
by automating it. And that's, that's a, that's a good principle and something that, yeah, maybe
a lot of the beginners should take a look at. Yeah. Yeah. And that, that speaks also to the,
should the beginner hacker know how to program a piece of that? And how much time do you think
hackers should spend on building a, some sort of ability in, you know, JavaScript, Python, you know,
some sort of client side or like scripting language, let's, let's call it a scripting language versus a
programming language. Oh, that's, that, that's, that's an entire debate here. Um, I mean, to do
this methodology that we just described, it's necessary, right? Yeah. Especially with the onset
of AI, I think it's a little bit tricky, right? Because you can definitely get away nowadays with,
you know, prompting in natural language and then being able to read code. Yeah. I think so. I, I think
it's probably not necessary even if you're looking to, um, even if you're looking to build that skill
set in a way of, of automating, you know, something to understand it a little bit better, you can
oftentimes do that via natural language prompting and then just modification. Yeah. I, I think
you, it's not necessary as a bug hunter to like code really well, but it's better if you code actually.
I, I, I have like in, in my mind, uh, an entire debate because I think like, I know some hackers
that do not know how to code at all. Right. Uh, but they are finding like some really crazy
vulnerabilities because they don't have the barrier of thinking a developer might have implemented
something. Yeah. And, and thinking, oh, you know, a developer couldn't have been this stupid,
you know, to implement it this way. Yes, they could have. Yeah. Or even like just try some super
naive and obscure thingy and just say, because they don't know that normally it doesn't happen.
And just because they don't know it, they're going to test it and it kind of worked once, you know,
Yeah. Uh, I feel like that hurts them more than it helps them though. Cause I've seen that a couple
times before and I've been like, oh yeah, you know, they tried that and then they kind of got lucky.
Right. But then, you know, how much time does that, does that person spend trying things that
will just not work? Yeah. You know, like, and I, and I know for a fact that it will not work.
Yeah. And, and that, and that's the other side of, of my, of my debate, like saying, okay,
but when you are going to learn, you are going to learn the concept and you are indeed going to reduce
the things that you are going to try because you think that people are implementing code that way,
but also by knowing more code and I think it brings a lot more value because indeed you can
automate those scripts and, and, and being able to script at least a little bit will reduce the friction.
Okay. Okay. So, so going, going back to that though, I guess, uh, putting the, the scripting
thing aside, we're all that guy that doesn't know that a little, a little bit, right. That doesn't know
how to script a little bit. Right. Because at the end of the day, we each have our own blind spots for
what kind of tech technology we're proficient with, or that we're familiar with in any way,
shape or form. So when we're building out this, like the rules, like you were talking about the
rules of the environment that we're, that we're in, we can make assumptions on, okay, well, you know,
I see this and this, which tells me it's probably a reverse proxy, but you know, you don't know that
for certain. And that's the, that's, that's the cool part I think about bug bounty, because bug bounty
takes a bunch of hackers from a bunch of different spots that all have different eyes and different
history and different background and different understanding of various technical components
and put it all together. Because sometimes you need the dude that's going to, you know, assume
that, you know, this is the environment and that my assumption is correct. And we go super
technically deep and we try this really obscure thing that would only work if my, my understanding
of the stack is 100% correct. And then you also have this guy that's like, what if I just put a
little tick here? I wonder, you know, what that does or, you know, just tries all of these naive
techniques to get the full coverage. And I think you need to be both those guys. Like this is the
answer that you need to be both of those guys. Yeah. Oh my gosh. Yeah. Yeah. You, you, you, you need
to learn, but sometimes you need like when nothing works and you really want to find a verbatim target.
And before like, you know, again, you, you, you've thought maybe on a podcast or on a conference or
something where that, that I've seen that you like to learn a target until you cannot stand it anymore.
Yeah. Right. You want to learn the, the, the JavaScript until you are, you know, going about to
be the world, you need to be the world expert on that specific application is what I normally say.
Yeah. And I think that in my opinion, before doing that, there is like, uh, the, the, the naive part
that you should, you should try it first. Like the, okay. Imagine I know nothing about anything. Like
I need to at least try some stuff before, uh, getting more in depth and then go back even after the
in depth part, go back and just say, okay, I'm naive again, but I know a bit more. What if I tried that then?
And it's not about luck or anything. It's like, sometimes you are so in, in a tunnel that you
can't see the bigger picture. Right. And just take a step back and trying to avoid putting buyers in
your mind because you became an expert on that specific target and like think I know everything,
right. You take a step back being naive again and you say, but maybe they just did that. And, uh, I think it,
it helps out where we're hacking. Yeah. Right. Yeah. I think so too. So, so we've covered a little bit
of like, how do we get the technical knowledge? We've covered a little bit of, uh, abstract,
you know, sort of high level principles about, um, hacking. And one of the things that I think is a
hard skill to teach and some people just have it straight from the beginning. And some people don't
is this whole concept of threat modeling is understanding where the boundaries are in an application and,
um, sort of getting those in your brain and figuring out a way to work around them. And I've got this
friend, actually, you know, he's, uh, he, he's come to some live hacking events with me and,
you know, I, I'll say this, you know, his technical piece is not there. He's, he's, he's not a IT guy.
Right. But, um, the instant that I talked to him, you know, he comes up with these scenarios and he gets
excited about the scenarios too. He's like, what if we could do this? Because I read this here and I read
this here and I said, well, you know, what, what if this happened, that would be bad for the
application. Right. And he just has that even without the technical piece, he has that whole
understanding of like, this is how I pretend to be an attacker and what would an attacker want to
do to this application. And that just came so naturally, um, to him. And I, and I've definitely
come up against some people where it's like, yeah, I tried XSS. I tried C-Surf, you know, I don't know what
to do, you know? And it's like, okay, well, you got to think outside the box a little bit here.
And you got to like, think about the actual trust boundaries that are not necessarily a part of the
technology. Right. That's what we see with C-Surf and XSS, right? We're dealing with a web browser,
we're dealing with HTTP. So there is a possibility of XSS and there's a possibility of C-Surf,
but we're also dealing with another layer of, uh, you know, complexity as far as the technology goes,
that implements some business case. And that's also a system. That's also a system that we can
abuse, right? That that's not, you know, this technology. And so, um, I guess a business logic
vulnerabilities, I think are just such a massive category of vulnerability that, um, threat modeling,
that getting that skill of threat modeling massively applies to. So have you approached this at all with
your, with your, with your, uh, mentee of sorts? And I don't know, how do you think people can address
and build that threat modeling skill? Yeah. So when I was a beginner, someone told me an advice is,
it was like the vulnerability that you are trying to find, uh, try to think how much, uh, of the
dark net people will buy it. Right? Yeah. That's a very, uh, simple solution, but yeah, that's a good point.
And I, I want to go a little bit further. That's beautiful. I love that. Yeah. Yeah. And I thought
like it was such a great advice because then I was like, yeah, I understand why the XSS on this
offshore website with no SOP or anything is not business relevant actually, right? Because there's
nothing that you can actually do to harm the customers or anything. And then once you understand,
like not even the business logic vulnerabilities, but also the business model of the company,
like what they are selling and what, what are their value as a company, then you need to aim on that
value. Right? That's something that I wish companies would be a little bit more clear about. You know,
I wish they'd be more clear about their threat model too, but some companies it's like, man, if you get
access to any customer information, it's like the end of the world. Yeah. And some companies, it's like,
oh wow, if you circumvent my whole payment model, it's the end of the world. And then some companies
it's like, oh, I don't care if you circumvent, you circumvented my whole payment model. All I care about
is avoiding fines for GDPR, you know, like it's, it's nuts. And you know what, maybe it's a huge
hot take, but I don't understand like sometimes on Fortune 100 companies that bypassing the, the,
their pricing model is not a vulnerability because most of the companies like their business model is
relying on ads. So on the data that they managed to acquire on, on their users. Right? And so this,
if there is a leak of data, it's basically as if you were, you were managing to bypass their business
model. But if you manage to find one of their tools, uh, that costs like $5 a month and you manage to
bypass that, it, this is not like the biggest vulnerability for them. It's, it's a, it's a,
it's a risk, you know, or it's a payoff thing for them too. It's a business decision at the end of the
day. Right. It's like, we accept this risk or we assign, you know, a $300,000 a year developer,
total comp developer, you know, four hours to, to, uh, actually fix this vulnerability. And okay,
how much money did that just cost me versus like, okay, you know, Ronnie gets free, you know,
Slurpees for life or something like that. I don't know. You know, um, so like, imagine e-commerce
platform, you bypass, uh, the, the, the, the, you bypass the payment, huge deal because this is their
business model that like that they're actually selling stuff. Right. But then you go to, I don't
know, like a, a company that has a, a license, but, uh, it's not actually the mainstream of revenue.
You bypass the, the payment. They are not doing any revenue anyway on that specific piece and it
doesn't cost them anything. So it's not like a huge vulnerability for them. And once you understand
the business model, I'm not saying like they're right to not pay you or downgrade you. I'm just
saying once that you understand like the best model of the company that is running, like how they make
money and you can threat that specific part, then you, you can do better business model,
like a threat model that will, if you find business logic errors.
Yeah. I, I, I get that. That, that does make sense. There's lots of, there's lots of nuance to that
situation, but I think there's also this piece of that isn't always how bug bounty works, right? Like
some of the people that have made the most money in bug bounty are not the ones whose vulnerabilities
will be sold for the most on the dark web, right? They're, they're the ones who have learned how to
game the system. And there are bug bounty hunters that just want to establish a baseline freedom in
their life. Right? So this is one of the things that I kind of talk about my, with my mentees is as
well as like, what is your goal for bug bounty as a part of your, as a part of your life? Right? Do you
love the, the aspect of like, let's dive deep and let's do security research and would you be doing
that if you, you know, weren't getting paid for it anyway? And that's where I think a lot of, uh, you
know, really successful bug bounty hunters come from. But then there's also this other side of like,
no, actually, I just want to be able to be a digital nomad. Right? And that's totally okay. You know,
like, I'm not going to try to shame the people that, that are just wanting to get back a portion of
their life. Right? Because I take, you know, I have that, you know, I'm self employed, I'm full
time bug bounty, and I love every freaking second of it. And I totally recommend to anybody who thinks
they can go full time bug bounty and pull it off to do it because it's like, super freeing. And I think
in those scenarios, it's like, okay, well, I don't necessarily need to make a ton of money or get
these super technical, you know, vulnerabilities, I just need to understand how to, how to get
how to game the system enough, how to add enough value to the right people who are willing to pay
for it to, you know, get my, get the freedom or whatever. And I do respect those programs that,
that will pay for vulnerability, even if it's not like something that is actively exploitable just in
the name of cleaning up their attack surface. Yeah. And I want to cycle back on the, on something that
is really interesting is that, um, what is your bug bounty goal? Right? And most of the
beginners, like, I think that there was a hack one report, uh, about that. I don't have like the exact
numbers, but, um, most of the beginners are here because they want to actually prove that they have
enough technical knowledge to, to get a job. Right. And that's how I used bug bounty. Yeah,
that's a good point. That's how I used bug bounty in order to get a job because I didn't went to,
to college. I'm really bad at classes, learning or, uh, anything like scholar. Right. And so I was like,
Hey, I'm allowed to hack companies and they're willing to, to pay for it in a legal, uh, fashion.
Right. And so I should use that as a, my way of writing my own resume. And your approach on bug bounty
will be different if, when you think like that, then when your goal is to actually have like a
streamline of revenue, because here you want to find like that niche vulnerability, your golden goose,
that you can milk until you get another golden goose once it's expired. But then, um,
once the golden goose is expired, I like that. It's gone stale, you know, it's a little bit, uh,
it's like the baguette we bought at the store yesterday. Exactly. I think, you know, exactly what
kind of vulnerabilities I'm talking about right here. I do. I do exactly what you're talking about.
Um, and then there, there, there is the goal of leaving off of it or the goal of just having fun.
And the way that you see bug bounty is going to, um, change the way you are going to do the research
of the methodology. Right. Um, like if you are spending two hours a week, uh, in bug bounty,
you want to find the vulnerability. If you're spending like maybe, I don't know, 20 hours a week,
but you are a beginner that just wants to learn how stuff works. Then you don't necessarily want
to find a vulnerability. You just want to actually understand how other people managing to hack into
those kinds of companies. And, and yeah, this will adjust your methodology too, I guess.
Yeah. For me, I think I allow myself to get distracted from this a little bit. Right. Because
for a long time, for me, it was like, and I guess to a degree as a full-time hunter, this is still the
case, but, um, I, I was focused on the monetary aspect of it is like, oh, well, you know, I can
make a full-time living off of this and I get this complete freedom in my life. And that's great. I
love that, you know, and, and I, and I do still have that to a degree, but I think I would really,
I really care more now about doing like more technical work, you know, in-depth technical work.
And I allow myself to get distracted by really good monetary opportunities, or maybe, you know,
I guess maybe I should be honest with myself. Maybe I care. It's thanks for the therapy right
now, Ronnie. Exactly. I appreciate it, man. I think maybe I should be honest with myself and like,
and say, I actually do care about the financial aspect of it, but that I think is stemming from a
place of, um, habit, you know, and whereas like at this point, I don't necessarily need to keep
grinding on the money aspect of it. I could focus more on the security aspect and, and the technical
aspect and get more fulfillment out of the whole thing. Um, but I still see these opportunities,
uh, popping up where I'm like, oh, you know, that seems like a good, you know, opportunity to make
some good money. Um, yeah. So I, I think as you move through this different stages of your life as
a bug hunter, your goals may change for it as well. And that's something you got to be aware of.
And, and this is also going to change like the targets you are going to hack on. Right. Um,
yeah. For instance, uh, when I was a beginner, it was okay. Any target where I can find something.
Yeah, exactly. What's the softest target I can find? How many times have we been asked that question?
You know, like, and, and so I, as I had like this, uh, fantasy that private programs, you find more
vulnerabilities and then the, the more advanced I got into, uh, backbunty, then I understood, Hey,
those big giant companies up there, they are like a huge attack surface and there is not enough people
to look at everything that they're exposing on, on the web. Right. And so my hunting change,
like the target change to more like those kinds of companies that work in a system where there is
like 15 principal engineers or distinguished engineers or stuff like that.
Distinguished engineers. Yeah. And dude, I want that title. Yeah.
Distinguished engineer. Yeah.
It's a title that exists.
Is it really? Yeah.
I've never heard that.
Yeah. Yeah. No, it exists. Uh, I'm not going to drop the company name, but,
and, uh, and where you need to have a process of 15 people approving,
a project or a fix. Right. And that's kind of company as a way to exposing stuff on the internet
that are way different than the smaller companies that run the private programs.
And when I understood that I'm like, Hey, there is, this is like, you know, uh, uh,
gruyere cheese. We are in France. Oh my God.
We're going to talk about cheese.
I've talked about cheese so much this week. I have never talked about cheese as much as I have
in this past week. Uh, yeah, that's a good point. Yeah. Um, like gruyere is a cheese with holes,
right?
You need to put that in context. Some people don't have that in the part of the world, I guess.
Dude. No. Okay. So it's just,
Tell me about the cheese.
Yeah. And so maybe a small startup running a private program will have like a small cheese.
So a small set of holes, but giant companies has like a way bigger market share. So the cheese is
big and there, and so there is more holes and that's how I approach my targets right now.
The metaphor works and I will fight anyone that's the other way.
So the cheese is big. He says, Oh my God, Ronnie, what are you, this is amazing. I love
getting the insight into your French mind. Every company for me is a cheese.
I mean, there is truth to it in the fact that like you understand that there is way more processes.
There is a continuous development. So it means that one feature will get redeployed, uh, maybe 20 times
in a day and with different, uh, code. And when you are targeting those kinds of companies that really
streamline a lot of code, you know, that you can come back, uh, let's say on Google drive, you can
come back every day and every day, there is a new request, a new feature, a new thing in the JavaScript
that you didn't manage to hack. And so this is where I think I can like, I was like a beginner
and I transformed to a more advanced hunter because I knew the processes of those companies.
And I knew that, uh, those were the companies I wanted to target.
And so this reduced the set of like all those amazing companies that are on hack on,
bug crowd or any platform, like, and you don't know which one to choose.
And then it reduced to like, I have 30 companies that I want to hack.
I'm in the same boat with you, man. I mean, I, I mostly just go after those bigger companies
that are pushing code constantly as well, but I mean, not to say that the smaller companies
aren't pushing code constantly. I think that they are as well. But, um, you know, when I was talking
with Douglas Day, he's, he's got a different approach. He just goes to each one of these, uh,
little small programs and with 2k crits and just, you know, spends four hours, you know, on each one of
them until he finds one that's like, oh, wow, this is really messed up, you know? And, uh, and then
just, you know, finds a bunch of phones on those. And so I think it's, it's not a one size fits all
sort of thing, right? It's like a per hacker.
Yeah. And, and, and, and that was like the, the, the beginning of the thought, I guess,
is that depending on your goal and, uh, on your bug bounty goal, you are going to approach the targets
differently. Like for instance, there is those amazing recall masters, right? Yeah.
Their target is not like one company. The target is like the, uh, the entire list of a bug bounty
platform, right? And they're running the automation on everything. And then there is those, you know,
French Rose and it's kind of hunters that are like, what is the funniest vulnerability I can find in the
world right now. Correlation IDs. Yeah. Oh my God, man. That was such a crazy drop when he, when he hit
us with that. Um, and the, like those approach are all valid, but they have different goals in mind.
One is to do quantity. The other one is to do quality and both of them will get like a lot of revenue, uh,
by the end of the day. Um, but you might have a diff like programs might have a different perception on,
on you. Like some programs will, if you are like this big recon master, they will see you as, uh,
maybe an automation scanner that is just pinging them like once a week, you know, but there is other
programs. Like when you are like this amazing hacker that are just going to see one report a year, but
they're going to have a sweat on their, uh, yeah, man, I want to be the one where it's like, yo, you get a
report from, from this and it's like, oh shit, you know, or, or, or you build a deeper relationship with
the program as well. And like, they're like, sup dude, nice report. Uh, you know, just finishing up the one last
week that you sent us, you know, that sort of thing. I think that's pretty, that's a fun part of bug bounty
for me.
And this human side that you say create the deep connection, you need to know with, with which
program you can actually create that. Because once you understand the process on them getting the vulnerability,
like some programs have like their own dashboard, uh, and they're just being fed by bug bounty platform.
And they're not seeing, they're not even seeing your name on the dashboard. You are just like a number.
Who cares about the reporter name?
Yeah.
You are just a number. And then there is the overall dashboard seeing a trend of like, oh, we got more
vulnerabilities, but we fixed those. And like, they are like, okay, we are happy about that. But then there
is the programs that are like, Hey, you remember when you sent that vulnerability two years ago? Uh, well, we want more.
We loved that report. We have it framed in our office. Yeah. Those are, those are great, man.
Those are great.
And, and that's just about processes because for instance, those bigger companies will have stronger
processes and they want to scale. They want to scale everything. And when you scale, you remove the
human side. And so you cannot create this deeper connection. And I think that as a beginner, you need
a deep connection to learn, uh, bug bounty with the people like you are working with, right? With the people
you are sending reports because they can give you the feedback that you really need.
Yeah. That's the feedback piece. The feed, that feedback piece is really important. And the, the feedback
cycle, I think is one of the things that I really liked about bug bounty in the beginning, but it's getting a little
bit more challenging now as things are becoming a little bit more volatile where, uh, you know,
there's so much volume coming in that the triagers are like, just, you know, kicking stuff that, that are
valid reports. And you start thinking, ah, is it my methodology that's, that's messing up if you're a
beginner, you know, or is it, or is it, you know, them not seeing this vulnerability from a technical
perspective? And, uh, it's hard, it's hard to say nowadays really. And that's why I get a lot of,
I actually get a lot of reports where people will ping me and they'll be like, Hey, um, I reported
this bug and here's the bug. Uh, and they, and ate it and are like informative. And I'm like,
and I always try to look at those and give them a little bit of a sanity check. Right. Like, uh, and,
this is not, I'm not volunteering this by the way, like, like, like I can't get to all of them. Okay.
Shit. I'm, I made a mistake to say that on the podcast. I kind of forgot, you know,
we, cause I was just sitting here talking, but, um, you know, I, I try to look at those and I try
to give them like, yeah, you're crazy or no, you're not crazy. That's like a valid villain.
And you need to start mediation or whatever. Um, because it's hard in the beginning to identify
whether you have correctly implemented some of these things you're trying to learn or whether,
um, you know, you're missing something or whether it's the triage. Um, most of the time it's the hacker,
just to be clear, but I think there, there are mistakes that happen for sure.
Yeah. And, uh, I feel that most shit I'm going to get, please, please, please guys, don't, don't do
this to me, please. But I feel that also most of the time when I saw that this is the hacker is because
there was a misconception of what the company was actually running, like how, how the company, uh,
was actually running, uh, like for instance, I have like someone that, that, that came to me like IRL,
right? I'm not like answering a lot of my DMS, but, um, uh, in real life. And they told me, yeah,
I sent a vulnerability to, uh, to Snapchat, uh, but they, they said that it was informative and was like,
okay, hit me. What was the vulnerability? It's like, um, well, you see that when you take a screenshot,
uh, on Snapchat, it sends a notification, uh, to, to the other person. Right. Uh, but they deployed
the web app and, uh, it wasn't necessarily the same thing. Okay. Yes. It's sending a screenshot.
And I was like, yeah, but what's the difference with you just taking, you know, a picture with your
phone, with another phone of your screen. They were like, oh man, that's true. Because that's not
like what Snapchat is trying to like, like, this is not like critical. Yeah. They're trying to add
friction to that, to that piece. Right. It's not necessarily a security boundary. Exactly. Those
are tricky. The, those sort of vulnerabilities are, you know, vulnerabilities output in quotes
are really tricky because you, you think you've correctly identified the threat model and there
may even be features, you know, but really at the end of the day, they like, Hey, we know it's possible.
We're just trying to make it less fun or less easy for people to do stuff. Those are, those are hard.
Yeah. And, and for, for instance, like really, really beginner vulnerability that I found was
like, uh, you could bypass a checkbox, right? Where it was on an adult site and, uh, and you
needed to say, uh, I agree to those and those and those. And I saw that the request in the backend
was accepting that you could not agree. And so in the backend, it was reflected that I didn't agree.
Right. And I was like, there is a logic problem in that request. And there, there, there is logically,
right. And so I sent a report and that's where I got the best program response because.
Yeah. From the adult, adult entertainment site. I love that. Yeah.
And, and because they didn't tell me like, this is informative. I'm sorry. They explained exactly
why it is informative. And they told me, what's the difference between you changing the request and
saying to the backend that, uh, you, you are not agreeing with those policies and you agreeing with those
policies, but just lying. And I'm like, yeah, that doesn't make any sense. And I respectfully said,
yeah, I'm dumb. Yeah. You know, it's a lesson we all have to learn. I think. Yeah. It is funny
though, when you bypass those and it does reflect it in the backend as well. And it's like, no, they
didn't agree, but we're not going to stop asking them anymore. You know? And it's interesting. I've always
wondered about the, um, legal implications of something like that. Right. Like if, if I were
to sue them and they were to look in their system and it'd be like, no, he declined the terms of
conditions, you know, and it's like, yeah, you know, why don't we let him use the app?
But then they can argue that the only way to decline is to actually put a reverse proxy. And so
this is some kind of reverse engineering. Yeah. Yeah. You know, there's no threat model there.
Yeah. Sure. But, uh, the, the, the thing where you think that the, the company, like you, you have
the company's threat model, right. And we, we have been talking about that. Like there's only the
company's threat model, but then there is something that we often forget. There is the state threat model,
uh, which is like all the laws that are applicable. And I saw a bug hunter that just found that there was
a company that is something unlawful because of a technical verbity. That was quite
like something really similar. It was just sending a request and then sending another request. And it
was doing something like regulatory that if you do twice, it's illegal for a company to do.
I've seen this too. Yeah. This is crazy. Yeah. I think we were at the same, uh, event. Yeah.
And they got like a major critical bounty because the company got, could have get in a lot of trouble
by the state. Uh, and this is like another threat model is like, if you're targeting a European
company, they say, oh no, your P, your P2I, mass P2I leak is just a medium because you have a name,
first name, email, and that's it. It's like, yeah, but GDPR.
Yeah. GDPR disagrees with you.
GDPR says that those data are PII data. And they're like, yeah, but they're not relevant PII data. And then you
understand that PII means that, uh, the more data points you have, the more identifiable someone is.
And so if in your subset of data, there's at least like, uh, uh, uh, many European, uh, customers that
can be identified to a certain location because of the data points, then there is a, a, a breach.
Yeah, man. I like that concept of like, let's brainstorm a little bit on what other type of
threat models there can be. So there's like the threat model for the actual company themselves.
There's a threat model for like the locality or the region, right? If you're in the, the EU,
it's going to be different than other places you are in the world. And then one that sort of came to
mind as you were saying, that was the threat model of the actual end user as well, where, you know,
you've got these, uh, companies that are providing like B2B services and there's some, or even if it's
not necessarily always B2B, but there is like a B2B component of it. Right. Um, and then, and there's
some sort of integrations with these, like if you can affect via the target, you're trying to hack their
B2B customers, um, sort of infrastructure, uh, that may not may have a, they may not have a giant
impact on the actual company, but it does have an impact on their customers. That, that can be a
massive, uh, threat model that's overlooked a lot of the time. Yeah. I, I really like this. And, and
I think that this is also part of the abstract thinking, right? Where you, you go to a mind map
and you're trying to check all the different layers that could be applied to, uh, to, to effect
model, to a vulnerability or to everything. So that that's what, when I was saying like hacking feels
like between as a, as a puzzle, because you just need to forget about what you see and you think on
another layer, new, uh, new paradigm, right? Where you are trying to just find all the layers and the
interconnection and just say, okay, what can go deeply wrong with the set of rules that is imposed?
Yeah. XSS is another example of this, right? Where XSS is actually, and this is why you have the scope
changed sort of aspect in CVSS is the XSS actually affects the user's browser, right? It doesn't
actually affect the website. It affects the state in the, in the, in the user's browser. Um, and if
there wasn't a browser, there wouldn't be a vulnerability here because, uh, you know, that
HTML isn't actually being rendered and it's not doing anything. Um, yeah. So there's that component.
There's, there's like that, the end user component. There's like this third party component. There's
the state level component. There's lots of various components to threat modeling for all these complex
applications. Yeah. And there is also like, uh, the part that is exposed, but there is also everything
that is happening internally inside the company and that we think that it's a black box, but there is
actually so many little interactions that end up being on the internet, like software software attacks,
uh, for instance. Yeah. Yeah. The software development life cycle. Yeah. That's a great point.
Yeah. DevSecOps. Oh, you can have like all your developers one day just putting your code base on
GitHub and like, no one noticed that. And I'm not going to say the company, but there is a company where
there is active developers because there are like 40,000 employees in the world or something like that,
where they're actively pouring internal source code on GitHub. And there is no keys or anything to look at,
but you just have like internal system knowledge. I love that for me. Yeah. I love that so much.
Yeah. And, and, and, and that's another way of, of, of, you know, think about, about everything. If
you have a mind map of this is the, where the company sits and this is like the, the, the, the country,
the region, uh, and this is like all the threat model. And then you zoom inside the company and you're
like, okay, there is that number of employees. This is the technical stack there. This is maybe they are
raising, they are doing a fundraiser right now. What can investors doing a fundraiser? Yeah.
They're raising a cycle. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So sorry. Yeah. Raising funds. Yeah. Yeah. Raising funds.
Investment round. There we go. Yeah. Investment round. So what, what the investors can get scared
about and then you zoom a little bit and you're like, oh, this is the technical stack. You zoom,
you zoom, you zoom until you mind map everything. And that's how I think we need to approach back.
Bointy is about, yeah. Abstract thinking of all the threat models. You need a company who's on board
for that because there aren't a lot of companies that will say, yeah, just anything that affects us,
you know, we want to know about, right. You see, you have a couple of those, but not, not all of them.
I love that piece of Epic Games scope is like, yeah, anything else that we own and you can prove it.
Yeah. We'll pay for that. Yeah. You know, that's, that's, that's pretty great. Yeah. That, that whole
overarching principle of looking at those lost components of the software development life cycle,
you know, these internal ticketing applications, the correlation ID stuff with the logging and
introspection. How does the, how does the SOC, how does the blue team actually investigate these
incidents as they're occurring and what sort of hindrances can you put into play or, or, you know,
how can you leverage that, that investigation, um, uh, to, to trigger other vulnerabilities?
Yeah. And as a beginner that can feel so overwhelming. Right. And I, I think,
Yeah, we kind of got off, off the, sorry, beginners that are trying to listen to this and thinking like,
holy shit, there's a ton of things I don't understand.
No, no, because I think this should be like some kind of North star, like to be able to understand that
many layers, but you need to start with the layer you are most comfortable with and more than comfort
is like the one that sounds the most interesting to you. Right. Uh, w w w w w again, as a beginner,
when I was starting, like the, the most interesting thing at the time was excess, like so many beginners.
And then there was like the request smuggling and I was like, what is that? It's so interesting.
It's so elegant. And so I wanted to find request smuggling and, uh, and then I learned from that.
And even all the knowledge that does add up in a vulnerability, sometimes, someday you are going
to go on an obscure application and you are going to say, damn, this thing that I learned like four
years ago is going to be useful today. And, um, I feel this happened to me recently, uh, like, like,
I, I, I was working, uh, with Shlomi and he did, uh, a blog post about that where he just pinged me
on this cord and he was like, Hey, I have like this, uh, I think it was 40 character hash. And I have
the feeling that is predictable. Uh, we, we should, you know, break it. And so the first eight Charles
were, where a timestamp and then there, everything felt so random and I, I advise you to, to read the
article, but the way I was thinking about this breaking was like a technique that learned like
four years ago on an obscure CTF and where they were like, okay, let's guess what the hash is doing.
Like how I, uh, what, what is computed and just trying like different methodologies until you get
the right prediction pattern. Right. And because I read that four years ago, I was like, oh, maybe I
can find it back and get their methodology and never used it in four years, but the knowledge
was useful at some point. So everything you do to learn something will be a payoff, even if you don't
find it. Yeah. It intertwines into other things down the line for sure. All right, man. What, what,
what else do we have on, on this beginner front? We didn't really cover the, the tweet, like we
actually plan to hear, I guess, um, we, the tweet actually says, okay, web fundamentals. And then we go
into a different set of, of, you know, various, um, kind of on the classes as we move into month three,
four, five, six, and then, uh, yeah, six through eight, we're doing code review and actually developing
sort of our speciality as a, as a hacker. Um, yeah, I think the, I think that piece of understanding
these various vulnerable patterns like XSS and C-Surf and that sort of thing, those have a couple really
solid purposes, right? They teach you those one classes, which you see, you know, on lots of targets,
so you can just apply it directly, but they also, um, apply some of those higher principles. Like we
kind of, like we talked about of, oh, injection. Okay. Injection is this concept that I need to apply
more widely. And I think we, you kind of get that through osmosis as well. You know, it's not
necessarily something you're studying and being like, oh yeah. Okay. Context breaks. That makes sense.
It's more of like, oh, okay. That's what context breaks looks like actually implemented.
Yeah. And then, you know, if my brain is, is, uh, trying to abstract eyes things, then I can start
seeing. There you go, man. Yeah. Yeah. So this is, this is what you were talking about before. Yeah.
So it's, uh, there's, there's dual purpose to actually learning those actual, those actual
vulnerable types and, and seeing how they're implemented. Yeah. Yeah. And also I feel that
when learning those vulnerable type, you don't need to learn all of them right ahead before starting to
try to find them. I feel like you, you need to pick one, the most fun one, right? The one you are
resonating with and you are just going to, to understand like in depth, where are the edge cases
of those techniques? Let's, for instance, pick SSRF. SSRF really, uh, pretty much widespread came in the
top 10, uh, new, uh, top 10. And, uh, and there is like so many fixes, uh, that are wide on the internet.
Like if you, if you just try to go type on internet, how to fix SSRF as a developer, right? You are going
to see all the fixes and you are like, what the developer must have implemented first, you know? And so
you learn those edge cases and that's where you come back to the RFC that you've learned before.
And you're like, okay, so what is an IP? What is it domain name? How can I bypass, uh, the fixes? And
you go so in niche that you can just try to just concentrate on that niche until you get sick of it.
And then you go to the other vulnerability. And I think Kevin Mizu did, uh, for me, he's one of, uh, the,
the best, um, trajectory in bug bounty right now. I, I feel like there is some other amazing people like,
uh, uh, Riotak or Matan that are doing like an amazing job on that trajectory. Uh, and Kevin is one
of them where he took XSS, right? Everyone is, is taking XSS as a, as a beginner friendly vulnerability
somehow. Right. Uh, he took XSS and he, it wasn't like, I'm going to find like reflected XSS on all
the endpoints. I'm going to check the biggest implementation of dumb XSS, like fix. And I'm
going to be specialized on how to bypass this implementation. And then he went to learn how
to bypass dumb purify. This is a bit more research, right? But he had to learn so many stuff. Like
I talked with him about that. Like he had to learn the RFC. He had to learn how to read the
the, the, the, the, the payoff is massive too, right? Like you see this with the, just moving
into talking about specialization, you see this with Alex Chapman, right? With the headless browser
stuff. Um, you know, Mizu with the, with the dumb purify sort of the aspect, Johan with the CSP
related stuff, right? You become the, the go-to person for the specific, uh, problem or the
specific stack. And yeah, I mean, I think Alex was saying that a little, almost all of his bugs
this year were collabs and he's crushing all of his goals just because people are like, okay, here's RCE,
you know, but I can't implement it because I don't know how to do, you know, V8, uh, you know,
binary exploitation attacks. And he kind of bridges that gap. That's that's specialization piece is
really nasty if you can master it. Yeah. And you don't need to over specialize. It's just maybe
about going in outside the comfort zone of the other people, right? Like you are in bug buoyancy
competing against the knowledge of everyone else that is, is, uh, hacking on the same target. Right.
And so there have a limit to the knowledge, especially if they're, they're hacking generally
as a checkbox. Right. And so you go to your XSS vulnerability and you're like, oh, I don't want to
find reflected XSS. I just want to find dumb XSS. And then in dumb XSS, you're like, oh, I just want
to find post message based XSS. And just, this is like a second layer of abstraction, but just post message
XSS is a bit widespread, uh, currently. And so if you take the vulnerability by like, what is the, the,
the, the nichest way to exploit it. And you just try to find that as a beginning, you'll find way more, uh,
vulnerabilities in my, in my opinion, that if you try to learn everything and hack in a general manner.
Do you think you should do that after or before you've sort of covered the general basics of all
the vulnerability classes? I think, uh, it depends on how much fun you're having. Right. Uh, this is
the, the hacking mindset to go deep and deep into, uh, the rabbit hole. And so if, if, if you don't like
SQL injection, don't go learn SQL injection. Amen to that. Hate SQL injection. Yeah. I don't, I don't really like it.
I'm not searching for it. It feels good. I mean, it's a good vulnerability when you get your hands
on it, but I'm not passionate about it. You know? Yeah. Um, um, yeah. It's not like something I enjoy
searching, but I do, uh, for instance, enjoy, enjoy searching, uh, the dependency confusion.
For any software, supply chain attacks, but I, I, I was in my head. I don't need, I need to stop talking just about that.
All I could think about is supply chain.
Yeah. No, um, because it, it has been like something I'm, I'm trying to.
I mean, you've done GraphQL DOS. You've done, you know, lots of other vulnerability types as well.
Yeah, exactly. GraphQL, like this is like a technology that is pretty much in every major
companies and you can find like some GraphQL somewhere. Right. And there is like so much of
an attack surface on GraphQL alone by default, that if you have fun learning just GraphQL, go just for
GraphQL, but you need to understand if what you are doing, there will be a payoff to that. If your goal
is to not just have fun, but also have the financial reward, you need to say, Hey, that obscure
technology or that obscure niche vulnerability, how much of that I can really find.
What do we think are the top, if we had the list right now, the top high value things for a beginner to
dive deep into? Well, what's, what are some of the ones that come to you? I mean, GraphQL is a great one.
Yeah. I think GraphQL is still very widely applicable. You just message mentioned, uh, post message
XSS. I think that's big. Um, WordPress technologies. Yeah. WordPress. Yeah.
Are still, uh, pretty big. I feel any framework or CMS with a special vulnerabilities, for instance, if
you like to hack on Rails, uh, and there is like an interesting attack surface that is just real
specific, right? Uh, so any framework, uh, maybe, maybe even libraries, uh, for it's a dump purifier
is library, right? But the attack surface of the purifier is gigantic. There is like a dump purifier,
maybe in every react front end that I've seen so far. Uh, not every, but I mean, that's pretty much
anything that has any sort of developer, um, base in it, right? Like you're allowing the user to be
also a developer with your tool needs to have some sort of piece of that.
An advice that I can give maybe to bug hunters and that I feel it's a good idea. Tell me if it's a
good idea is instead of messaging all the top hunters or the ones that are successful in what they are
doing, because they were answering hundreds of DMS, go message a developer of the technology you are
trying to, to hack like someone on LinkedIn. They're pretty responsive, man, to be honest. Uh, like at
least that's been my experience, just kind of talking to these people that are passionate about
these projects. Yeah. Just, if you want to hack on Rails, go talk with a Rails developer and just ask
them like, how do you implement your code? You don't need to really know how to code the Rails application
in order to hack it. You just need to at least understand the fundamentals, right? The abstract of it.
And so just ask, Hey, what's your developer life cycle? Uh, when you deploy such application and then
try to think, okay, that's how he's doing it. So I need to hack it that way. Um, and I feel that's
like a good piece of advice. Like if you go niche, try to be part of the ecosystem that you are targeting.
Like if you are hacking on WordPress, go follow some WordPress developers, go follow, uh, the, the,
the discussion, uh, if there is some. Yeah. The change logs, the, get some data feeds for those.
Yeah. Yeah. Just go into the developer community because they are the one producing the vulnerabilities.
Like your top hunter, like, like for, for instance, you, when I message you, you are not producing any
vulnerabilities, you are finding them, but the guys that are, uh, uh, like the people that have, uh,
producing those vulnerabilities are just out there. Right. And they're talking publicly and you can go
learn from them their mistakes. Right. And I think I've learned more talking to developer
about code review stuff than actually to hackers. Yeah, man, there, there have been some really
crazy times in the live hacking events where I'll, I'll come up to the developers on like the first
day and I'll be like, Hey, if you were going to search for volumes in this code base, where would
you look? And, and sometimes they'll, they'll be like, uh, you know, screw off. Like, you know,
I, I'm not going to tell you that, you know, but sometimes they'll be like, oh, you know, I really
think this is sketchy. Right. And, and I just remember one live hacking event where I did that and it was just so
sketchy the whole area that they pointed me to. And I found like 15 bugs on that. And I was like,
man, that was a really good call. Ben, Ben taught me that, that actually, um, that trick.
And, uh, and for the people that don't have access to live hacking events, like more beginner people,
like just talk with, with, with some people on the internet that are actually developing the,
those technologies. Like, uh, there is like in web hacking, there is some discourse, there is some
forums, there is some Twitter accounts, uh, and, and that, that I think could be quite responsive.
Yeah. Just going back to the, like what niches could be good right now. Um, I, I think there's
an area for somebody who is a gadget master, like somebody who really just builds automation solely
around collecting non-vulnerability gadgets, you know, like, like, let's say I need a,
some ability to redirect on the specific target, right? It doesn't even necessarily to be an open,
but it could be a semi open. It could be, you know, whatever. I just need some ability to
redirect on a target, having that, you know, around, I need a CSP bypass that's on this specific domain.
I need, you know, a, a cookie set gadget, you know, around, right. It's having somebody who their
specialty, their niche could be collecting those gadgets and then working with the community to, to
fill the needs of various exploits. And you kind of see that with Eric, right? Eric does that to,
to a certain extent, but I think he focuses more on gadgets that are also vulnerabilities rather than
gadgets that are not vulnerabilities in and of themselves, uh, local storage. Um, uh, if you're
able to like poison or invalidate some data in local storage, right. That could be, that could be a gadget.
Those sorts of things could be interesting.
Eric does that. Um, maybe also SSO, uh, anything related to that's a good one. Yeah.
Yeah. OpenID connect, uh, implementations, uh, that, that one's crazy actually. Yeah. If you
master that, that would be really cool. Yeah. And I feel that, um, this is more like a developer
implementation and that's you, you don't really need to learn that much of HTTP to be able to at least
find some vulnerabilities. Right. Saml. Like Saml, if you just master Saml alone, I feel like that
would be, and, and we've seen that actually, there's a hacker that's going to come on in the pod
at some point when the vulnerabilities that he wants to talk about have been, uh, patched. Um,
it means somebody, there's somebody who does that. And I think there's room for more of those as well.
Yeah. Uh, the, the, the principle, if you want to go to, to a niche is like your niche should be a
niche of expertise, but not a niche of implementation. Right. Because there are some people that focus
like on a technology that is used maybe by, by maybe 100 companies in the world. Uh, right. And
there is some bigger technologies that no one has a security expertise on. And that is not, I would say,
not too hard to build it. Uh, right. Uh, for instance, you can focus solely on Laravel. Uh,
Laravel is getting bigger and bigger every year. And I feel that there is like a huge PHP community
insecurity that is targeting it, but not that much backhunters. Right. That could be a niche,
right? Because widely implemented, but not enough expertise or eyes on.
Yeah. We, we, we see, we've seen the ticket trick stuff before, right? When you're focusing
on these sort of ticketing systems. Um, one of the things that I've, and this is sort of related to the
post message XSS, cause most of those are actually implemented, you know, uh, a lot of the post message
XSS occur in these sort of gadgets. But I think, uh, a lot of times you'll see on like the WWW or on
like the marketing website for a specific company, you'll see these like little chat bots that are
meant to, you know, connect you to a sales person or like help or add support or whatever. And, uh,
a lot of times these are implemented just by dropping a JavaScript file onto the main site. And, uh, then they
need to communicate back to their, you know, main, their iframe or like their main server in some
capacity. So you see the post message stuff there. I think those things are riddled with vulnerabilities.
Yeah. And I have a couple zero days actually. I need to talk to people about how to spray
in those specific plugins, common ones. Yeah. But, and this is like, depending on how much knowledge
you have, uh, how you will approach those, uh, niches, but I don't think you need to be like a, uh,
really like really an expert before, uh, diving into a niche. As I said, when I started bug bounty hunting,
I just tried to find any vulnerabilities in, uh, WordPress plugins. That's a niche, right? Uh,
but because WordPress is so much implemented, there is so much plugins, there will be a lot of,
it's also, it's a reflection of the rest of the ecosystem too, in the WordPress environment piece,
right? Like, like, you know, sure WordPress plugins, you know, you get the source code and stuff like
that, which is not something you, you see always, but they're vulnerable to the same sort of thing as
other things, right? C-Surf, you know, XSS, uh, SQLI, if you're lucky, you know, that sort of thing. Um,
so especially those niches that are reflections of the bigger system as a whole.
C-Surf, and when I was trying to find vulnerabilities on WordPress plugins, I was
just concentrating on XSS. It was just, so, so it's-
C-Surf, so you weren't even looking at the other role types?
C-Surf, no, no, no. If, if I, it was obvious to me as a beginner, I was like, okay, I'm going to
to search for it, but not everything was obvious to me when I was a beginner, right?
And so, but something that I understood at the time was XSS. And so I was like, okay, I'm going to find
XSS on those plugins. And if I don't find anything in the plugin, I would go to another target and do
that again until that one day I didn't have any more targets or any more plugins. And I was like,
okay, let's try a new approach.
C-Surf. Yeah, absolutely, man. Yeah. Lots of, lots of niches to be explored. I'm trying to rack my brain.
It's late. It's getting late here. So I'm not, uh, not much left in there for racking, but, uh,
definitely tons of niches. I'm interested to hear what the community drops in the comments as well. And
like interaction on, on Twitter afterwards, because there's always like, you know, whenever we talk about
these sorts of segments, people always are like, ah, you know, what about this? What about that? I think
that'll be, I think that'll be helpful for them, for the community. I think if it's possible for the
beginners, like, uh, watching the podcast or, uh, maybe on the comments or on Twitter to tell us
like, what was the hardest part of learning web hacking or what, what is the current struggle?
Because, and I'm not talking like about finding a target or anything. It's just about like really
the core knowledge. What is it for them right now? Because I, in my opinion, again, when I was a
beginner, I hit so many, so many walls and the only struggle that I really had was the motivation,
right? Like it was the resiliency that when I was hitting a wall, what could I do to, you know,
overcome the obstacle? And that motivation was like my main struggle. Uh, but I know there is some
other struggles that are more like on the technical side and less on the human side. And I think it will
be cool to know what are those and how like people can facilitate them.
Well, what was your biggest, uh, success in overcoming that motivation piece?
It's when I found like, for me, it was when I found my, uh, my niche, right? Like my, when I created a
comfort zone that was outside of other, outside of the other people comfort zone, but where I felt like
I had the expertise right now on that subject.
Do you think that was because you were experiencing success or do you think that that was
because you respected yourself as a hacker?
I think it's because I had an hypothesis and the hypotheses were getting truer and truer.
And so I got confidence into what I was doing.
So probably more success.
Yeah. I, I, I feel so like I, I'm, I'm the, that part of, uh, I would say the, the researcher,
security research community that I can't say that I'm a really hacker because you need to say, uh,
yeah, you, you know, like originally to say that you are a hacker, you need that other people to say
that you're a hacker, right? Uh, because hacker is your North star is like what you want to become.
And this is something that you always need to grow, uh, and, and trying to evolve. Right.
And I feel that sometimes we forget that we are not at the top of our field and our knowledge and
that we need to go further. So I'm not considering myself as a hacker because I want to one day become
like a true lead to hacker. Yeah. You always got this, this moving picture of like what the ideal
is. Is that what you're saying? Yeah, exactly. And, and that's what drives me that motivates me is that,
uh, one day I can grasp the idea of being a hacker. Uh, and I feel that,
yeah, again, that's depend on your goal. Like if, do you want to become a hacker? Do you want to
become a bug bounty hunter, a security researcher? Like you need to figure out that and create
motivation around that.
I think we have to hack the motivation as well. That's one of the things that I kind of talk about
with the, with, you gotta hack the motivation. Yeah. Yeah. You gotta hack the motivation as well.
I mean, you, you got it right. I mean, because at the end of the day, that's one of the biggest challenges.
And I think one of the things that I say about hacking the motivation is, you know, identifying
when you're making progress, even though it doesn't feel like progress, when you're covering
endpoints, when you're finding gadgets, those are all progress. And I think as a beginner,
as you're starting, one of the nice things about having like a checklist or whatever is like, okay,
I can check off this little piece and I can say, okay, well, you know, I am making some progress here,
whether it's in your learning curriculum or whether it's in, you know, your actual assessment saying,
okay, well, I've assessed this target for XSS on this one endpoint, you know, that's progress. And, and
I, you know, you, you trust that, that progress or that progression is a part of validating your
hypothesis on whether this, this whole process will get you to the point of, you know, finding a
vulnerability or being a hacker or whatever you want to, whatever you want to delegate as your actual
end goal. And then, you know, if it doesn't just like you do when you're hacking, you have to adjust
your hypothesis and say, okay, well maybe this isn't really how it works. Right. And then,
and then you construct a new hypothesis and you keep on, keep on pushing with that.
So you do abstract thinking.
Yeah. Yeah.
I can do abstract thinking.
We're just sucking back to that, like to the fact that you need to think on another layer.
And that I feel that's the main, the real entry point of actually starting your back booty career,
even if you are like, I really, an expert of insecurity or like a beginner in everything is that
your ability into thinking differently than just what is in front of you. Right. If that makes sense.
I don't know if you have like a better wording for that.
No, I mean, I think that makes sense. Yeah. I think you've got to think, um, you know,
you could say think outside of the box. It's a bit of a, of a cliche, but, um, yeah, trying to pop
up that extra layer. Right. It's almost like one of those techniques you, you implement in, uh, in
meditation. Right. Like I remember like closing my eyes and trying to focus on, you know, my breathing
or whatever. And then the, the coach of the meditation coach or whatever would say like, oh, you know,
you're going to have these thoughts come to your mind and make sure you don't like, you know, push
that, you know, you get too upset with yourself and that actually happens. You just kind of have
the thought and then you just, you pop right out of the thought and go one layer higher. And I think
you can go one layer higher or you can go one layer lower, um, in hacking and you can see results
on, on both sides of those. Yeah. It's like walking the path and visualizing the path that you are going
to work. Like this is two different things and two different ways of hacking. Dude, you think
we're high right now, you know, we're sitting here like, yeah, man, it's like all of hacking is like
a cloud and you just pop out of it. I feel that metaphors really helps though. Yeah. You think so?
Okay. Well that, that makes one of us. All right, man. You want to wrap it there? Yeah, let's go.
All right. That sounds good. Thanks for coming on, dude. Yeah. Thanks a lot. Peace.
Thanks. And that's a wrap on this episode of Critical Thinking. Thanks so much for listening.
And if you want more critical thinking content, head over to ctbb.show slash discord, join the
discord. There's lots of great conversations and chats going on over there. And if you want to support
the show, there's the discord subscriber tiers, which give you access to masterclasses, AMAs, hackalongs,
exclusive scripts, and an exclusive chat channel with us. We'll see you there.